well obama is president at a time where
there's no question that certain other
powers in the country are asserting
themselves they're asserting themselves
economically first and foremost and
politically in the world system such as
it is and the notion of unquestioned
american singularity is ending and
that's very painful for people to take
on board and something even more
complicated that the two main powers
well take that rrr let me check that let
me go back that two of the big powers
two of the big rising powers are
questioning the orthodoxy that we
believe in even on the right and the
left which is that somehow a liberal
economic system you can obviously argue
about the parameters of that go hand in
hand with a democratic political system
China and Russia are challenging that at
their very basis China is implicitly and
explicitly arguing to the world that
they don't need political Liberty in our
sense or democracy in order to develop
at the rate that they're developing the
Russians the same thing I mean this is a
kind of soft authoritarian sometimes not
so soft under Putin and Medvedev the
degree of democracy there is decorative
is not an independent judiciary the the
legislature is in the pocket of the the
executive and there's a kind of social
compact in Russia the social compact
with the people is we will let you
develop economically and let you travel
and let you build businesses so long as
you stay the hell out of politics and in
China there's roughly much the same
thing going on this is a deep deep
challenge to the American understanding
to the Western European understanding
even the Indian understanding of the
course of historical development of
successful society I think obviously
Obama is committed to the
model and the Western model and any
Democratic model that also is
essentially capitalistic but i think
obama is more willing to talk about this
multipolar world in terms that certainly
has some of his predecessors would have
been scared to or reluctant to for
political reasons you know I think
Fareed Zakaria has got the frame of it
right in his book and Zakaria says that
that it's not about the decline of
American power so much as the rise of
the power of others India China Russia
now Brazil and so this dream that a lot
of Americans had after the collapse of
the Soviet Union post-1990 one of
Americans singularity in every sense was
very very short-lived
to my mind there's no question of what
the end of the Israeli Palestine
situation has to be must be and this has
been evident to most of the main players
for many years there has to be a viable
contiguous Palestinian state a connected
Gaza and West Bank connected somehow by
bridge highway would have you with its
capital in East Jerusalem I it is
impossible to conceive that the refugee
problem can be consol by actual
repatriation of refugees into into
Israel proper that they'll be obviously
some some degree of aid or money going
to a new Palestinian state and also
Israel has to be Gary received certain
kinds of security guarantees and those
areas where big settlement blocs are
there has to be land swaps to to make up
for that that's that's the endgame and
even pretty conservative political
actors in Israel Noah and all but the
most radical Palestinian leaders know it
the real difficulty has been getting
there and it's going to get more and
more and more difficult it's going to
get more difficult because of the
polarization in Palestinian political
society between Hamas and the West Bank
government it's going to get more
difficult in Israel itself because of
the growth in population of religious
and conservative elements and the slow
do munition of secular more liberal
leaning populations you also have a
great big Russian population there that
tends to be conservative so time is not
on the side of a decent resolution there
it's very very complex but the more
somebody like Netanyahu is is unwilling
to make a leap of history and is going
to be more obsessed with parochial
political interests and coalition
politics and all the rest the more
difficult it's going to get on the
Israeli saw it and that's its and
there's no question by the way that the
Israelis have real concerns about what
would happen the day after a Palestinian
state is established so this is this is
a highly complex question always was but
the end game is going to be what the end
game is going to be otherwise it's going
to be a disaster what I think this is it
I think there's an illusion among some
right-wing Israelis and right-wing
Israeli politicians and the illusion is
this that by establishing a security
fence or wall it's cut down on on
terrorism immensely and it's given the
illusion of a kind of rough stability
that they can live with it net and they
can have their cake and eat it too that
they can keep all these settlements in
the West Bank and they can have a rough
security and they can live with a few
missiles going over the wall in Gaza
this is this is just a an illusion
especially when it comes to relations
with other other countries not least the
United States it's an illusion for
everybody
you know there have been reports and I
first read them in David Ignatius this
column in The Washington Post the other
day that the American administration the
Obama administration realizes this this
has been a mess in the last several
weeks this is back and forth about these
apartments in East Jerusalem and and and
all the I hesitate to call it minutiae
because they're important but that the
Obama administration with the
encouragement of some outside forces
other countries wants to have a much
more comprehensive plan it's it's
difficult to see how that plan could
work but the alternative is even worse
this this illusion of a continued status
quo is to me extremely dangerous
well it's important to know where the
solution comes from the illusion comes
from the notion whether it's whether you
agree with her to disagree with it is
that settlements removed from gaza gaza
became came under completely under
Israeli control and in the Israeli point
of view it's an only reward was that
missiles came coming over the wall and
missiles that would ever become more and
more sophisticated and reach places for
more distance than steroids and and will
hit major population centers and
missiles that are inevitably going to
come from places like Iran so it also a
lot of Israelis and not just very
right-wing Israelis wonder why the
Palestinians have had a habit of looking
away from potential resolutions to this
question as they did in the late Clinton
administration and believe me I know all
the arguments back and forth about what
that deal was wasn't was not and how it
how it improved and how it changed right
up until the end of the Clinton
presidency I do get all that but somehow
one has to agree if not all the
specifics of the Clinton view that
Yasser Arafat did not allow finally came
up short of being a revolutionary leader
rather than just a rebel leader let me
change that that that finally Yasser
Arafat did not want to go that extra
yard and felt he could not sell this
dealer could not sell himself on this
deal that went from Camp David to Taba
and then taba to so a lot of Israelis
wonder what it is that the Palestinians
actually want and that's where the
anxiety comes from this is not me
agreeing with that I'm just trying to
analyze why this politics occur
you